we turn now to actor simul liu and his
amazing rise to stardom the 33 year old
had a whirlwind year after starring as
marvel's first asian superhero leo was
named one of time's 100 most influential
people now he has a new book we were
dreamers about his life growing up as an
immigrant kid in canada nancy chen
talked with leo about his success the
ups and downs of his childhood and the
life that his parents dreamed he would
have
it for the village
after the blockbuster success of chiang
chi in the legend of the ten rings i am
your host tonight as well as a fellow
member of the 2022 time 100.
simulio has become one of hollywood's
hottest stars this past year has been
pretty incredible for you
yeah it's been it's been almost
embarrassingly successful
i don't really know how to really
process it all i'm still kind of
struggling thank you so much and as sold
out crowds line up on tour for his
best-selling new book cass yeah sure
it's not slowing down anytime soon what
did it mean to you to be cast as the
first asian marvel superhero it meant
the realization of that childhood dream
to matter to be seen just the idea that
people who grow up in ordinary
circumstances can be called to do
extraordinary things but as the 33 year
old details in his memoir we were
dreamers his family life was far from
ordinary and often tumultuous this book
is written for all of the children of
immigrant families who struggled to
navigate their two cultures who dealt
with trauma at home but also dealt with
trouble fitting in at school and just
you know struggled to make sense of the
world because they were constantly
trying to figure out which one they
truly belonged in leo spent his early
years in china separated from his
parents after they immigrated to canada
for graduate school i was left in the
care of my grandparents my yeah yeah and
my night and i you know i lived a
wonderful life with them until i was
about four and a half when one day my
dad showed up at the door he said hey
i'm here to take you away to your new
life you know i was being sold on this
this utopia that was like this is
everything you ever wanted
but i had everything i ever wanted you
know
life with his parents near toronto
instead brought turmoil both physical
and verbal amplified by unrelenting
pressure a painful experience he
revisited by interviewing his parents
for his book you talk about your
childhood as a war zone at times yes yes
absolutely i mean you know home was not
a safe space for me especially during
those teenage years it was like you know
i went to school to escape
being at home and i would find reasons
to hang out with my friends so that i
wouldn't have to come home i want to
talk about the things that happened in
the hopes that families like ours will
read it and will choose to do better you
know because there were so many things
that that really my parents either
didn't see or didn't consider or just
were too anxious about you know the
bare necessities of survival to really
worry about movies became a source of
escapism the idea of acting a fantasy
did you always want to be an actor i
would say yes
i was always so fascinated by movies
growing up and the more fantastical they
were the more i just wanted to dive in
you know growing up as an immigrant kid
you just feel like nobody sees you
you're completely invisible and here
were all these movies about you know
take star wars it was like this kid that
grows up in this distant planet but is
being told he is the chosen one you have
a special destiny and i used to imagine
myself in that situation i wanted to be
that guy instead leo attended business
school but was laid off after just eight
months as an accountant a moment he
describes as freeing pushing him to
pursue his dream of acting i heard him
my parents didn't realize this at the
time but the reason why they were
working so hard and sacrificing was so
that i could have the opportunity and
the freedom to define my own success
i'm not closing the door this is my
manager's office
in 2016 he landed a role in the
groundbreaking canadian sitcom kim's
convenience
[Music]
not long after leo was up for the role
of a lifetime as shanghi i called my
parents and i and i was like guys i'm
freaking out i don't know what to do
and um
and my mom said
whether you get this job or not
doesn't change how much we love you
it's just a matter of time for you you
know we believe in you and
that was everything i needed to hear you
know i felt like
alone you know as this kind of lone wolf
person against the world you know i had
been doing pretty good for myself but
i just felt like with the support of of
my family behind me and my community i
mean i could i could do anything and
he's proven he can he says his
relationship with his parents is now
stronger than ever and hopes his success
helps create more representation for
asians in hollywood i'm going to be
unapologetic about who i am and where i
come from and i'm going to be a
representative you've hosted snl
time 100 most influential people the
world is your oyster what is next for
you i want to tell the stories that
really matter so that you know kids the
asian kids watching today can can turn
on the tv and feel that we never did
which is
this was made for me
[Music]
this was made for me nice yeah very nice
piece
you like the style there yeah yeah the
no shirt with the buckle man quite a
journey yeah i like this story though i
mean it just shows you everybody has a
story you would not know that he had
that background and that kind of
has
came from such a tumultuous place yeah
to be doing what he's doing and going
out for that that big role the one that
we all know him for his parents just
saying no matter what and then calling
your parents proud i like that we got
you we got your back regardless we're
proud of the understanding of his
parents journey as well and they're now
in a better place than they were when
they were younger having that awareness
that's a nice nice capstone yeah